[Musique]
lorsque nous arrivons en seine et marne
cet après-midi le ciel est noir et l'eau
commence à gagner certaines routes
nous atteignons la commune de souppes
sur loing ici les feux tricolores
semblent en service l'eau monte
l'angoissent aussi chez les habitants se
passe là bas ça le terrain ça monte en
fait c'est en train de monter vous
partez ouais je vais partir ça monte a
présenté ce matin c'était pas top star
maintenant sa vente
c'est vraiment angoissant sur les
hauteurs de la ville
c'est un compte à rebours ne faut pas
les laisser on va le bouger en arrivant
j'ai pas le coeur du sujet comme toi
toutes les voitures doivent être évacués
à la hâte
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que cela vous
fait la queue toute la rue oui vous
savez combien de voitures alors ses
preneurs on est combien de voitures avis
ouaip et même plus
la voie ferrée ressemble déjà à un canal
et des centaines de personnes ont quitté
leurs habitations
nous accompagnons les pompiers dans une
zone reculée du village emmanuel l'eau
dépasse les 1 mètre 50 par endroits on
distingue à peine ce portail un peu plus
loin une voiture engloutie
pour les pompiers il faut s'assurer
qu'aucun habitant ne soit encore en
danger
[Musique]
dans cette rue seules deux familles
refusent de partir
ça va ça va oui encore meilleur il ya
quatre personnes d'un matériel en
mandatant nathan de consommer les
chevaux moi si l'eau monte encore quand
les chevaux soit là on restera là tant
que l'on ne montera pas plus haut que ça
ça rentrera pas ici au pire les chevaux
les rentrera dans le salon et n'hésitez
surtout pas à nous rappeler 6 à 4 soit
les pompiers n'arriveront pas à les
convaincre
ce soir 780 personnes ont déjà été
évacuées de la commune devenue ville
fantôme
[Musique]